I would up his logic I'm saying we right
here at Lake my hometown with that
studio and working on a special record
for the HOME key Karen and s I'm saying
to walk up to about to bring home to my
Lou what about brother on kick it nice
to meet you nice to meet you okay oh man
I need a song I needed walk-up song
something that's gonna bump those
speakers in the stadium you know play
something swish I like that one but I
feel like the one for there's got to be
like I got a sound like a new air Ledo I
know you got something switched it's
what he's cooking over here I'm about to
go in the booth and handle my business
buddy
yeah I see I see you with the Alpha
bounces own took that data yeah swag it
out there don't turn me down turn me up
my mom on a crime that's what's up pull
up in a beam of instability that's a
start who's all right I run it back
almost got the hook-up Wow sup bro but
look this yo record bro I feel like you
got to come in here you gotta say
something this yo song you know I've
always wanted to be a singer you know
what it go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh-oh-oh-oh
check the sass I'm on the charts whoa
don't never like take loss but you gotta
pay the cost to be the boss
I gotta floss all this ice a distraction
when I talk with some gang she caught it
rented mouse only tell me where white is
it this hard get out of here hurry up
pull me out let's go
[Music]